All the world's a stage and all the blah,
blah, blah.
We all know how that one goes. But if you are
a theatrical type, there's a good chance you
became smitten at a very young age.
The sweetest sounds I ever hear are still
inside my head.
Seeing the wonders of a life you might be
part of one day. Full of stories and
experiences you can only dream about from
the eighth row, behind two beehives in row seven.
The most entrancing sight of all is yet for me to see.
And the dearest love in all
the world is waiting somewhere for me.
Is waiting somewhere.
Somewhere for me.
Once smitten, though, then comes the work of
classes and training, of speech and technique.
Honing your craft as you pound the
pavement in New York City, auditioning for
anything and everything, all in pursuit of
that moment in the spotlight where you hope
someone might see you, really see you and say
those magic words, "Where have you been?"
But what if those magic words never come? And
it's only rejection over and over again, year
after year, and near miss
after near miss.
Until you realize that near miss has become
your life.
How do you keep at it with any hope?
Thank you. Very nice. So, someone's shown up
who's not on our list.
Maybe a walk-in? I do know her.
She's capable, a little vanilla, but we've
got about ten minutes until lunch.
Yeah, sure.
Loretta Durkin, you still there?
Yes!
Yes. Hi.
Oh, hi. I'm so sorry. I thought- my agent
assured me that I was on the list.
And do you have the pages for the role of the
nanny?
Yes. Is it just the one scene?
That's right. Whenever you're ready.
Enough. Enough of your questions, Detective.
I'm happy to tell you who I am and what it is
I do without your insistent probing.
I am a caretaker of children to whom I'm given
charge.
Am I a substitute for the child's true
mother?
Some would prefer I say 'no', but I believe I
am.
I must be.
Their mother when it's only me with them.
Because a child needs to feel at all times
safe. They need to feel protected with the
kind of ferocity only a mother can summon.
It's no matter if they were born of my own
flesh.
Would I kill to protect a child in my charge?
That is the question you have for me, I
assume, Detective. To that, I would say
without so much as blinking, I would kill
without compunction.
But the sake and safety of any child in my
care. So.
Now you have your answer.
Where have you been?
Um-
But when you finally do land your dream,
your moment in that spotlight...
I said, Where have you been?
Oh.
How far would you go to hang onto it?
Oh, thank you. Oh, thank you.
Oh, God.